my guest tonight's a comedian and
co-creator of netflix's
f is for family he uh also of course
plays
migs mayfield in the mandalorian please
welcome our really good friend
bill burr bill how are you what's going
on oh thank you
thank you all seven of you and the four
kevin harts yeah
is he in the black section of the crowd
yeah it seems like
they've moved up to the middle progress
i like it
it's it's so nice to have you here
you're one of my all-time favorite
guests
uh always entertaining uh we've had such
a good time together over the years
you know we really have yeah it sucks
that you're renting this
we're ending this version of it i'll
come back with a cooking show or
something
what are you doing are you going to be
on what hbo max are you allowed to say
that on this network are they going to
get upset
no no they're cool with it i think
they're all aren't they all the same
thing
they're all in bed together everybody i
mean
everybody's owned by one company now
we're all working for exxon
so yeah while working for exxon and they
have a very low budget exactly
they don't have a lot of money that
reminds me back in the day when i used
to do like
chappelle show yeah that was like viacom
and that was the funniest thing ever
they'd always be like we don't have a
lot of money
so you'd like book a part they'd be like
yeah you're playing a swat guy do you
have any combat boots
and you'd be like yeah no i don't any of
your friends
do your friends and they're viacom
but it was just like this isn't my job
my job's to book the part
so we would just give the ladies [ __ ]
down there going hey you play you're
playing a
a blacksmith you got an anvil any of
your friends do you know
can you get one let's lug it over here
it's like no i'm not doing that
i don't know that's always been uh yeah
i've been paid a lot in exposure
throughout the years this is great
exposure i'm just gonna trash everything
i've ever done
i love the 80s strikes back that was
this great exposure it's great exposure
they wouldn't
we had to fight them to give us cab fare
granted it wasn't the highest art bill
what would you do for a klondike bar
well i'll tell you
remind me back in the day i worked in a
restaurant in north carolina that was
slowly going out of business and at one
point i was the best boy
slowly slowly always it was a slow bad
day they put a five-star restaurant in
the middle of this stupid strip mall
it was doomed from the beginning so um
not to mention it was sort of the 80s so
a lot of people were
you know they were ready to work we'll
put it that way yeah
um amped up um i was the busboy
i was the grill chef kicked on a
mesquite grill and the dishwasher
all at the same time i remember those
[ __ ] thinking about it this morning
this is that irish thing where you never
let [ __ ] go
yeah i came running in the back i taken
off my chef half i ran out
and i bust the tables i came in the back
and i said hey we're out of glasses
and this guy who was on work release
from prison
he goes well why don't you wash some and
he goes
ah a novel idea
i remember he said like he was this
well-read guy
this one is on
he was in jail so i was scared so i was
like okay and then i just
washed them and probably burned the
shrimp brochettes
that's a tragic story you know i'm going
to say something bill
i'm going to say despite that rant you
just had where you got your
your temperature got up a little bit
your heart rate raised a little bit
you do seem calmer to me we were
chatting a little bit when you got here
seems like you've calmed down i know you
had your second child
recently fatherhood coming down um
fatherhood made me have to figure myself
out
because i didn't want my kids to go
through you know
some of the stuff that i went through
not saying it was all bad but some of
the stuff that i went through so
um i just kept trying and failing with
the temper
and i ended up taking mushrooms
you took mushrooms to help you with your
temper no i was sh
no i didn't do that it inadvertently
helped me i just took it cause i was
like all right i'm gonna be 53
i've never tripped like am i gonna miss
out on that i'll do it once
i'm in the desert that's what you're
supposed to do right so i did it
and you know i didn't do a lot of it so
i i sort of mini trip you know what i
mean like the tv looked like it was
gonna you know get bigger and fall on me
right sink looked like it was breathing
or whatever right um
but then after that i was sort of left
with this
uh profound sense of loneliness and not
feeling loved
right so i'm literally laying there
going what the hell is this i love my
wife and i love my kids and i figured it
out i go oh this is how i felt growing
up
i get it and then i i was like i need
i've been running from this this feeling
that's why hey
i might do stand-up i fly helicopters am
i cool do you like me
and i i just like the pandemic really
just not having anything to do
right just slowed everything down and
then all of that smoke
just kind of came back and i was trying
just you know organizing my office
and i couldn't stay in front of it so i
was kind of like all right i need to sit
and figure out what this
is so it's kind of funny i ran from it
for 30 years
and in three months i've i kind of
figured it all out
put like all the pieces together so um
it's funny now i haven't like flipped
out or yelled in my house
and uh and but now i'm going up i still
have that need to be liked so now i'm
like going up to my wife like you know i
haven't yelled in a while
have you noticed yeah am i a swell guy
do you like me so i still have that
crushing need to be liked
but uh i'm not like flipping out
yeah i feel great i feel like light and
all of that
and uh it's nice and i'm not worried
about the whole oh if you get happy
you're not going to be funny it's like
no maybe i could have a new
like empathetic you know way of going at
[ __ ] while still you know i will still
forever rip apart inconsiderate
people who i deem in my own dictator
world
as inconsiderate people right right i
had a murderous thought and target
with this [ __ ] self-involved woman
who's just shooting this [ __ ] with like
the person that's registered the six
people behind you
just do the transaction and get out of
there and like all the stories were
self-serving and about herself
and i just felt it yeah i just felt it
coming up you know we got a tropical
storm developing you know just
so you feel even though you're
enlightened now and you've found
peace you're so enlightened i'm not i
i've figured out that i
i why i'm [ __ ] up but i'm not
enlightened okay i'm still a [ __ ]
don't you dare compliment me conan okay
in that chair
what about i mean there's a lot of
people uh that are upset about a lot of
things these days
um you know people are arguing about
whether they should get vaccinated or
not have you gotten vaccinated yeah
yeah i'm up for it too i i'm like you
know if they like dick trying to kill me
which doesn't that conspiracy i love a
conspiracy it doesn't make any sense
you don't think the anti-vaxx conspiracy
lines up that they're that they're gonna
that they're secretly trying to kill
each ot
all of us for for population control no
because what they would do would they
would be killing
all what they call the sheeple so all
the people can be like all the people
that go what are we supposed to do
okay they're going to kill us right and
then just be left with all the fonzies
with their leather jackets
who don't want who are too cool to
listen to people like
they got a nightmare who's gonna who's
gonna dig their ditches for him
yes it just doesn't make i mean if you
wanna say that they're gonna come up
with something to thin the herd
i will go with that but they would never
do a pointed attack
on people that are gonna do whatever
they say yes yes
they're eliminating the wrong group if
this is the plan so maybe they vaxxed us
sheeple so then they can have a second
vacci
of uh covid thing come out to kill all
the cool people that
hit a jukebox and it turns on
[Laughter]
so anyone who's anti-vaxx is a fonzie
that's what you're they're just all
false
look at me we have a couple of ron
howard sitting here right sure yeah i
look like i'm at a younger age i look at
it like i'm now and
i like to think i'm the oscar-winning
director ron howard
you're still ron figuring himself i'm
still i'm towards the end of the happy
days run
i might direct the movie right around
when he started dating laurie beth
sorry that was a deep cut yeah uh okay
so the problem is in our culture now
if you have a weird belief you can find
a source that caters to that belief
and you don't have to read anything else
because the internet called the internet
yeah that's why i don't listen to
anybody's theories anymore
unless i just go did you get this
information at the library
yeah okay if you got it at the library
i'll listen to it because the library
has the decency to break up
information between non-fiction and
fiction
meaning this happened and this is just
some [ __ ] people made up
you go on the internet everything is
presented as
as non-fiction and then that's why dude
in my lifetime for the i'd say for the
first 47 years
that nobody thought the earth was flat
right
and in the last five years all of a
sudden people you know are coming out
telling me there's an
ice wall that you can go look at like
there's these ice walls
like we're basically in this giant bowl
of i don't know cereal or something yeah
but then once again i'm like all right
i'll go with that but like
what is the upside to telling me
a sheeple ron howard right
that the world is flat as round if thing
when it's really flat yeah yeah what is
the upside of doing that right why trick
us why deceive us
yeah what what do you get out of doing
that and they can't seem to answer it i
go what you need to do is get a pilot's
license
and go for your instrument rating and
then when you see vor
signals and realize one of the things
that blocks it is the curvature of the
earth
you'll stop trying to rent a boat to go
look at the
you know people are flipping out about
masks and on both sides like they're
people that say
uh you know i shouldn't have to wear a
mask i don't want to wear a mask i don't
buy it and then there are people that
um i love those people what yeah you
like the people that flip out
yeah don't wear it yeah don't wear it go
kill yourself
that's awesome cause i have to be honest
with you i know a lot of people died
from covid but i'm starting to see the
traffic come back and uh
i selfishly thought i wish it killed a
few more
i'm being honest god it's an honest
selfish thought god that i had
so just specific commuters we've got to
be clear here
people that i don't know or love
that i would never miss it's it's 100
selfish
okay you just want to know what's funny
is when i looked out there all the real
people were like this and all the
cardboard people were still
so i think overall i think it made sense
yeah kevin hart agreed with that one
yeah
all four of them no three of them went
for it one of them just
covered his face didn't want any part of
it um what do you make of this uh bill
and melinda gates divorce you following
that
that's a crazy story no i haven't but i
know if i say
that she's going to get a ridiculous
amount of money that she didn't earned
i'm going to be labeled a misogynist
of course she's going to get a
ridiculous amount of money yeah well
yeah
what do you mean why she's been a
partner
uh stop it what stop it stop what
just stop with this [ __ ] that like
dr dre's wife hanging out with them and
that's why he came up with the
headphones
like i don't understand like what do you
talk to your wife about are you sitting
there going over plans and blueprints
you're not it's all like you know you've
been working a lot lately
yeah which isn't even supportive wait a
minute
hey i am i am liberal when it comes to
this [ __ ] cause when britney spears got
divorced from that backup dancer i he
should have got a tracksuit
and a laptop okay
those were all her songs and i'm gonna
say no but he supported her
but this has nothing to do then what
you're saying is this has nothing to do
what i love about bill
oh you know what i love about bill gates
i love that he has so much
[ __ ] money that even if she cuts him
in half he's still got
15 million 15 billion yeah yeah yeah so
he's still there
yeah he can enter that second part of
his life you know
maybe wear an open shirt get the
convertible
to track something like you know get a
third of his age get like an 88 christ
little baron
no no get the ferrari california
you know the gt right you get the gt
with the top down you know yeah yeah
yeah and go attract some gold digger
that's gonna like you know build up your
ego do that for a while
do you think that's what he's gonna do
you think he's gonna start i think if
you buy that car that's what it comes to
you like there's a danger to buying that
car
that big yell they see that big yellow
prancing pony and they just come out
they come up out of the manhole covers
all these gold diggers
like a zombie movie
you make a lot of money you got to be
you can't buy a car like that it
is a that is a gold digger magnet and
they are so good at it they can look and
tell if
it's rented or not they know where to
look for the sticker
i'm just saying predator behavior goes
both ways
but this sort of predator behavior does
not fit the narrative
i see i see yeah okay okay uh
of all those those white people branding
themselves as good people rather than
just trying to make money off the
suffering of others
who just all of these people were
sitting there acting like that like
they're not like
everybody is up in the head if you
really listen to your inner monologue i
thought that
stuck in traffic i actually had the
thought uncontrolled
selfish moment i wish covid killed more
people so i could get to the comedy
store
quicker jeez i thought i know it's a
wrong thought
right but you're admitting that you had
that i've wanted to kill and kill again
but i don't do it
i don't do it either that's the
difference between being on the outside
so you think
[Laughter]
you know a buddy of mine told me he
watched this documentary
on uh the son of sam and he was saying
like dude you gotta see it he didn't
kill all those people he had help
and i was like dude i'm not watching
this documentary he goes nah they proved
it
i go they did he goes yeah yeah they
proved it i go
how did they prove it they go well they
went in they asked david berkowitz they
asked him they go did you kill this guy
he's like yes did you kill this guy he's
like yes did you kill this guy he goes
no
he said no i go oh you mean the guy who
was talking to a dog
that guy that guy said that's your proof
i don't know not everything this is why
i like this sweater yeah because it just
lets people know that i'm this
curmudgeon i'm really steering in i'm
going the opposite
of what i'm supposed to be doing right
now i'm supposed to be doing hgh get
that hulk face going right right
get some uh hair plugs yeah and uh what
else is what's the last thing what's the
trifecta of
of of that oh the botox oh yeah you got
to get botox you got to go botox you got
to do the hair plugs and then you do the
hgh
and then your organs grow so you still
kind of look fat
but you're going the other way this is
so much cheaper you're wearing a sweater
no cause those people need a sidekick
right they need the side kick in the
movie that looks like this
right all right so i'm gonna fill that
void but you are you're in the
mandalorian
that's a huge deal for you for anybody
that was a huge you're in the thing
that's the one show that everybody
watched during kovid
i have to question you about this
because you used to make fun of star
wars
you would go out of your way to make fun
of star wars yes you did no i didn't i
only did it when it came out and i saw a
long line of people looking like they
were going to enjoy themselves
and i did my comedy job was i made fun
of them and i tried to make them feel
stupid
i do that all the time that is the job
of a comedian so it had nothing to do
with star wars it made fun of steve jobs
when he died and all the nerds that
loved his little big little big little
[ __ ] that he did on computers
yeah i made fun of it yeah so what you
do is when you see people
enjoying themselves or filled with any
kind of glee anticipation of a wonderful
day
what do you like to do you like to take
that away i come in in my x-win
fighter to get into your world and i i i
i say my world
i don't watch that seemed like you took
it a little personal i did not
i like the original lost in space you
know that's what was my thing with
oh i loved it he just couldn't he
couldn't
hold his composure no who knew
just like anything that was happening
but i loved when [ __ ] wasn't happening
he would he could be sit in the calmness
of being lost in space with the
spaceship that
did the spaceship work yeah it worked
they would go from planet to planet but
they were lost
but i'm talking about island in space
the 1960s lost in space they had this
ridiculous uh character dr smith
who said you bubble-headed booby
and uh he would yell at the robot all
the time and every episode
he would take the kids and try to sell
them to aliens
so that they could be taken off to an
intergalactic zoo the parents would foil
it at the last second
literally try and take their children
from him and his punishment at the end
would be like no blueberry pie for you
dr smith
and he'd go he tried to kill your
children it was an abuse
he didn't he tried to leave him behind
uh yeah yeah awful guy
no one's gonna care about this part
check it out 60 is lost in space
it's just absolutely fascinating it's an
abusive relationship
right he's lonely he didn't have a
partner out there
no no his partner was a robot maybe he
felt like if he got rid of some of the
stuff that these people loved
that he had a shot at luff that's a very
good
read on it i'm just saying think he has
compassion
for dr smith but not for anybody else
yeah
star wars you dr smith child killer
maybe you should think of it from this
time
yeah it's you know you're all over the
map you're all over the map
you know i don't think i am i think i'm
right on it
but that's but congratulations that's
how human beings are
everything i'm saying totally makes
sense to me right
i mean if you could if you could hear
the applause between my ear right now
yes now listen i no i know i'm an idiot
i know i'm an idiot
uh yeah and i should have read a lot
more in life and i didn't there's
there's still time now touring
touring's a huge part of your life
crowds laughter
when are you going to get back to it is
it starting to open up now right
are you going to get do some uh indoor
shows soon yes
uh actually the comedy store is open now
limited capacity
and i have to tell you after a year of
doing shows
outside and dealing with everything from
mosquitoes to helicopters to doing shows
near
like highways and stuff to actually be
inside
and there's no distraction i went on
stage i felt like i was on steroids it
was so
it was so easy like i built back up my
hellroom muscles that i used to have
when when you first start out as a
comedian you basically do stand up
wherever they would let you like i went
to a long time ago me and this buddy of
mine rick delia did a
show at the uh the fisherman's feast
in the north end in uh in in
boston and we were so excited that
nick's comedy stop called us like one of
the main clubs and we were like oh my
god we're in we're in and it was like an
afternoon gig he was standing in the
streets after like there's a band
playing like
whoa and all these italian women like
hanging out the windows like
i felt like i was in like the pope of
greenwich village or something and we
had to go on up
after that and just absolutely just bomb
like that's like the whole first eight
years of your career is like every third
gig
is as bad as that so after you
make it and you start selling tickets
you actually get
worse you're not as good because people
you
rather than having to get them they're
there's they're like yours to lose yep
and i kind of built that stuff back up
again so i don't know how long that'll
last but
um i feel like it's gonna be an ex first
of all
like a renaissance i mean i could be i
know it's not in
either of our nature to be optimistic
but i keep thinking
people have been so many performers have
been put on ice for so long
yeah that there's all this pent up
frustration
observations anger and it's all going to
come out in the arts
in some great way yeah i'm hoping it's
going to be
a uh a positive thing
i don't know i just wish they'd get rid
of cnn and fox news and the ability to
leave a comment
on the internet and i think if they just
did that everybody would kind of relax a
little bit more
and it could be more sort of uh you know
you're on this side of it i'm on that
side and sort of give each other [ __ ]
and then
enjoy each other's points more so than
uh
you know all the capital letters that
people
type in and [ __ ] yeah um because i am
all over the map though i get [ __ ] like
during
uh i get [ __ ] that i'm a trumpster i get
[ __ ] that i'm a socialist i mean it's
literally
all over the map but you make both sides
angry
i guess that's what i do i never looked
at it that way yeah it's a beautiful
thing
all right no one's happy when you're
talking
i think that's going to be my wife's new
ringtone
that's going to be your new ringtone all
right uh you can see bill in theaters
across the country this summer and fall
on
big bur sorry
you can see bill you can see bill in
theaters across the country this summer
and fall on
bill burr the tour when i later have a
degenerative disease they'll say that
was when they knew
that i mispronounced that right you get
worried that it's already coming on i do
i do too yeah whenever i mispronounce
something i think oh that's when it
begins
this is now now i was seeing movies and
like a week later i can't remember what
happened
it's kind of cool because i can watch
them again
i've always wanted a place that will
give me an operation that destroys the
part of my brain that's seen godfather
one and two
so i can see it again from them again
for the first time
yeah that'd be cool come back again
no you looked horrified which is
appropriate can you imagine if i had a
big scar right here
and i was running a fever all the time
and you said what happened i went i had
a part of my brain that i've seen
godfather one and two destroyed
but it also attaches to my my speech
center well no i would
when my brain went it was like well
there's drugs you can take that will
destroy that part of your brain and
everything becomes new again but i don't
know if you under even understand the
context of it i've been watching a bunch
of uh
and listening to a bunch of movie uh
music from the 70s and movies from the
70s
just simply because that's when i was a
kid
and i feel like that's before uh
whatever happened to me happened to me
and uh and so i go back there not like
that was the greatest time
i came over i came over listening to the
dirty harry soundtrack
yeah it's wild you feel like you're
gonna go solve a case
there's some then there's this weird
woman's voice going like this weird sort
of drugged-out
thing i know exactly that i know that i
know that soundtrack well yeah
yeah so i uh by the way one of the most
uh fun things
i've done uh just you know the last
couple of years was you called me up
when you were playing the forum
and yeah you said come on down i have
a drum kit and i'm with some musicians
and you before i do my show at the forum
we get to screw around
in this amazing space so i came down you
said bring your guitar and we had a
blast you're a great drummer it was
really fun
oh yeah thank you that was great that
was really fun comedian but i
i uh yeah we had uh dean del rey
michael devon i'm trying to remember the
people we had a mix of comedians
yeah failed musician comedians yeah and
like real deal
uh guys like michael plays uh with
everybody playing like white snake and
all that stuff before all this crap
he could play everything yeah it was
great yeah yeah so there's a clip i wish
i could
if i could find it on one of my phones
we did uh van halen
ain't talking about love and there was
some guy who had like the van halen like
tribute guitar and he
you know was crushing the solo you came
down would you play van morrison it was
such a great time i think i played van
morrison yeah
we ended up playing for like almost it
felt like three hours and i had such a
good time and then when i stood up i had
no energy left and i was like oh my god
did i just blow it
you got to do this yeah now i have to do
the show but fortunately the
the fear of screwing that up
becomes like adrenaline yeah and i was
able to go out there um and
uh yeah i forget what that sounds like
even having like a crowd so
right we'll get back to it yeah
hopefully yeah all right let me make
sure i
get this all right you can see bill in
theaters across the country this summer
and fall
on bill burr the tour for full
tour dates visit billburr.com and the
mandalorian of course
available on disney plus massive
conglomerate
no one here is getting that money bill
burr
that's great thank you